la conception de la scène T était
extrêmement amusante et, évidemment, nous avons commencé ce
riz au début du processus,
il fait juste un travail extraordinaire et
remarquable sur cet ensemble, libérez
Yvonne la plus grande scène sonore du Royaume-Uni,
données moyennes par scène, nous avons construit sa
rue incroyablement  rapidement, nous l'avons construit en
moins de 10 semaines et il a fallu une équipe d'
environ 100 charpentiers sculpteurs
et peintres en plâtre l'attention portée aux détails est
quelque chose que nous aimons vraiment
faire même si vous voulez juste faire une
petite coupe de quelqu'un assis dans un
magasin c'est  tant que nous devons donner à Tom
la chance qu'il puisse ils ont construit la
rue à Pinewood une rue parisienne
avec le café la caféine a été en partie
inspirée par le Flatiron Building New
York c'est un bâtiment que vous pouvez voir
est sur le point de se tromper sur le
côté droit et a une sorte de solidité
cela donne littéralement l'impression d'être dans une
rue de Paris en 1830 il y a de l'eau sur
le sol et hé il y a une vache vous
oubliez que yo  vous êtes sur un plateau pour un
acteur britannique travaillant à Pinewood fait
toujours partie du rêve mais travailler sur
un plateau de cette envergure est absolument
magnifique Eve s'est surpassée avec un plateau
je pense que ça va être un
film incroyablement étonnant à regarder
vous